[Musique]
à la télévision dans les journaux ils
sont de plus en plus visibles avec les
attentats de 2015 et l'épidémie de la
covid-19 cette année le savoir-faire des
14700 soignants du service de santé des
armées dont 70% sont militaires et 30%
civils n'est plus à démontrer
une expertise de pointe acquise depuis
300 ans dans de nombreux conflits
grâce à ses 120 métiers la médecine des
armées a su s'adapter en innovant
toujours plus pour soutenir des soldats
exposés à des combats de plus en plus
intenses
alors qui sont ces femmes et ces hommes
qui construisent aujourd'hui la médecine
de demain quelle technologie dernier cri
utilise-t-il pour garder un temps
d'avance
il y a du sang un peu partout
là ce que je pourrais faire c'est
repositionner un petit peu
tu veux que je reparte sur un m au gars
[Musique]
soigner en urgence
des blessures de guerre comme sur un
champ de bataille
cette scène est une simulation
celle d'une attaque terroriste sur le
sol français
un exercice préparé par des médecins
militaires pour des urgentistes civils
en médecine préhospitalière en tout cas
au SAMU souvent le quotidien c'est un
seul malade c'est rare d'avoir beaucoup
de blessés en même temps on l'a vécu aux
attentats
et on a eu le sentiment que on était pas
suffisamment bien préparé ou en tout cas
on ne pourrait se perfectionner et
bénéficier justement de l'expérience
militaire
pour ce genre de blessés qui était pour
nous assez nouveau finalement depuis
parmi les programmes d'échanges
existants ainsi que de formation à
l'école du Val de Grâce
on enlève les mains je remercie dans des
situations critiques comme celles que
nous vivons en ce moment ou lors
d'attentat ces partenariats civils et
militaires sont essentiels pour mettre
en commun toutes nos expériences
respectives et c'est pour ça que le
partenariat qui existe de manière très
étroite et depuis des années tant de
points de vue universitaire donc
formation que du point de vue santé
publique donc soit réellement appliqués
aux patients ce se met en place et se
pérennise de manière tout à fait
naturelle
[Applaudissements]
en cas
civiles ont été formés certains sont
même allés plus loin les premiers formés
à ces stages là mais également des
professeurs des universités ont été
particulièrement sensibilisés à cette
dimension-là et donc ont intégré la
réserve opérationnelle du service de
santé des armées à cet égard par exemple
dans le stage qui vient de se déroulent
en ce moment il y a un tiers de
personnel militaires d'active et il y a
deux tiers de formateurs qui sont des
personnels de réserve qui ont intégré
toutes ces techniques de médecine au
combat et qu'il est délivre à leurs
camarades civils on est d'accord que là
la médecine pré-hospitalière classique
n'a pu n'a plus aucune efficacité parce
que là on a pu dans le système je
comprends mon malade et je soigne un
malade c'est je l'identifie des lésions
des signes cliniques et je traite des
signes cliniques cet après-midi les
stagiaires vont pouvoir appliquer les
techniques de médecine de guerre
étudiées pendant deux jours
le scénario un afflu massif de blessés
victimes d'explosion et de tirs de fusil
d'assaut un exercice grandeur nature
[Musique]
on travaille surtout sur l'hyperréalisme
en simulation donc les choses de de qui
peuvent être très très choquant sur le
plan visuel très dur sur le plan
émotionnel et l'idée c'est de sorter nos
soignants de leur zone de confort
habituel et donc de les mettre en
situation extrême et voir comment il
réagissent dans des situations de stress
de fatigue extrême voilà d'où l'intérêt
de d'aller un peu au-delà des limites
que l'on peut voir parfois dans un monde
civil où on prend entre guillemets plus
de précaution parce que le contexte ne
nécessite pas d'aller dans un tel
hyperréalisme
[Applaudissements]
on est venu au chercher auprès des
militaires ce qui savait le mieux le
faire c'est la prise en charge des
blessés de guerre on avait on avait été
confronté à des blessés de guerre on
avait moins l'habitude de que de le
faire on est allé chercher leur
stratégie opérationnelle pour être le
plus efficace encore plus efficace que
l'on avait été et en travaillant avec
les équipes en travaillant avec les
sentinelles voilà c'est cette immersion
et bénéfique
tu peux venir aider s'il te plaît ici là
c'est quoi c'est une plaie
un exercice érintant pour Rodolphe et
Sandra infirmier du Samu de Nantes on
est conditionné un peu notre métier à
garder notre sang-froid c'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire là on est dans une idée
marche de réflexion qui est quand même
très différente de ce qu'on fait au
quotidien donc on tous les curseurs sont
un petit peu un petit peu rouge quand on
rentre parce qu'en fait on est hors de
notre zone de confort donc on essaie
voilà super expérience ça nous mobilise
et ça je trouve que ça nous ça nous
renforce un petit peu enfin en tout cas
ce soir
riche d'un service de santé des armées
depuis longtemps à la pointe de
l'innovation tout ce qui est le service
Santé des Armées toujours innové
l'histoire le dit puisqu'en 300 ans
d'histoire
il y a eu de nombreuses innovations de
nombreuses innovateurs rythmées par les
grands conflits les grandes crises
sanitaires et ces innovations donc
étaient à la fois nécessaire pour
prendre en charge les blessés sur le
terrain mais également pour faire face à
des nouvelles formes de de blessures ou
de maladies
c'est l'exemple de la grande guerre face
à ce conflit à la durée et à l'intensité
nouvelle le service de santé des armées
a dû s'adapter
on lui doit quelques grandes avancées
médicales de ce siècle
dentiste et chirurgien vont expérimenter
innovés pour reconstruire les visages de
ces dizaines de milliers de soldats les
gueules cassées
c'est l'essor de la chirurgie et de la
prothèse maxillo-faciale il y a 100 ans
[Musique]
à Marseille l'hôpital d'instruction des
armées lavérants cultivent cet héritage
[Musique]
une des particularités de son pôle de
chirurgie maxillo-faciale la
reconstruction des visages à l'aide
d'une imprimante 3D dernier cri un don
en 2017 de la Fondation des gueules
cassées
[Musique]
cet outil permet d'imprimer des
répliques de crâne en résine ou des
tissus du visage après modélisation à
partir d'un scanner ou d'une IRM comme
cette mandibule utilisée pour préparer
l'opération de Julie
[Musique]
pour vous montrer
depuis le début de la réparation donc ça
à vous c'était avant avec la fameuse
tumeur qui malheureusement vous avez
grignoté tout l'os à ce niveau pour la
chirurgie j'ai dû vous enlever 7 dents
depuis la prière molaire ici grâce à la
technologie 3D maintenant on a la
possibilité d'imprimer
véritablement une réplique du patient à
l'échelle et cette possibilité ça permet
au chirurgien d'une part de mieux
appréhender la chirurgie de même
réaliser son geste et ça arrive moi ça
m'est arrivé plusieurs fois de réaliser
le geste chirurgical sur cette maquette
en résine et de se rendre compte un peu
des difficultés qu'on aura pour gagner
du temps le jour de la chirurgie et pour
avoir un guide de ce qu'on va pouvoir
réaliser brancher au niveau du cou du
côté du patient aussi le bénéfice est là
pour moi il y avait quelque chose à
enlever mais je pensais que c'était plus
enlever une tumeur quelque chose mais
qui était pas je voyais pas forcément
les dégâts que ça pouvait faire parce
que sur une radio on voit une tache
noire donc une tache noire ça peut être
n'importe quoi et effectivement quand il
m'a montré la mâchoire imprimée en 3D
donc avec un trou je me suis rendu
compte qu'effectivement il y avait
quelque chose de beaucoup plus important
et ça m'a vraiment donné une autre une
autre image de ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
allait m'arrivée Arthur du moment où
j'ai pu où j'ai pu avoir une protège
j'ai pu reprendre quand même une
activité ressortir un peu plus avec mes
enfants parce que c'est vrai que du coup
on était un peu plus à la maison on
avait un peu moins envie de sortir et
c'est vrai que ça permet de retrouver
une vie un peu normale tout est en ordre
juste on fera la semaine prochaine le
détartrage comme prévu
c'est aussi le cas de Sébastien un autre
patient civile de l'hôpital militaire
l'Aveyron opérée après une morsure de
chien au visage qui lui a arraché le nez
son cas n'a pas nécessité l'utilisation
de l'impression 3D mais il bénéficie de
toute l'ingéniosité de Laurent depuis
plus d'un an en attendant que son nez
soit reconstruit un soutien précieux
autant humain que médical parfois
bouleversant pour les patients
notre niveau on se met à faire une
prothèse qui tient pas la route
demain c'est double peine pour toi donc
tu vas trop retrouver avoir être en
marche de plus sortir et nous le but
c'est que tu retrouves une vie sociale
que quand on interagissent et puis voilà
de ressentir ces émotions là
[Musique]
tu as l'impression de retrouver une
partie de toi pour moi c'est plus beau
cadeau que tu m'as fait
c'est d'accord
c'est dur
je sais quand on est parti la capitale
militaire l'avait rend accueille
majoritairement des civils comme Julie
et Sébastien qui bénéficient de
l'expertise issue de la prise en charge
des soldats blessés au visage un
accompagnement à 360 degrés jusque dans
leur rééducation physique et psychique
nous avons une réelle culture du retour
d'expérience justement puisque les
besoins en innovation les besoins
nouveaux remontent du terrain remontent
des besoins
en opération par exemple et c'est à
partir de là que
son formuler donc les besoins et que
nous nous orientons nos recherches et
nous innovations et plusieurs exemples
c'est l'antenne de réanimation de
chirurgie de sauvetage qui a permis de
répondre à de nouveaux besoins
opérationnels en termes de mobilité de
réactivité de rapidité d'exécution
l'antenne de réanimation de chirurgie et
de sauvetage dite Arks est une structure
issue du retour d'expérience des
opérations au Sahel un outil médical
parfaitement adapté aux conditions du
terrain
cet espace de 30 mètres cubes pesant 5
tonnes se montent en deux heures
déployée à proximité des combats il
permet de prendre en charge beaucoup
plus de patients
[Musique]
à Toulon à l'hôpital l'instruction des
armées Sainte-Anne 4 jeunes médecins et
infirmiers de la Marine nationale
rejoignent le laboratoire de biologie
médicale
en formation ils vont apprendre à
utiliser un tout nouveau laboratoire
embarqué installé sur les bâtiments et
sous-marins depuis deux ans
une dizaine de tomates d'analyses
biologiques la version miniature de ce
que l'on retrouve en milieu hospitalier
un appareil qui va vous permettre de
faire des bilans biochimiques très
complets alors ça se passe comme ça donc
on va mettre un échantillon sanguin au
niveau de l'orifice central ici ici vous
avez tous les substrats lyophilisés
lorsque l'on va introduire le la
cassette dans l'appareil celle-ci va
tourner à grande vitesse va répartir
l'échantillon dans les différentes
cupules et au bout d'une quinzaine de
minutes on aura des résultats ça permet
de d'avoir des un panel biologique assez
étendu comme vous pouvez le faire dans
un laboratoire de ville et puis des
analyses complémentaires de biochimie
pour savoir si le patient a une
infection ou d'autres pathologies
associées en plus de ce qui avait été
mis en place depuis deux ans sur la
formation à tous ces automates
classiques contenus de l'urgence
sanitaire et de la crise actuelle
le service de santé donc à déployé sur
différents bâtiments les automates de
PCR donc ces automates permettent de
poser un diagnostic d'infection ou pas
par le coronavirus
et donc depuis le mois de juillet 2020
ces automates sont disponibles sur une
douzaine de bâtiments et nous formons
plusieurs fois par mois des infirmiers
des médecins à la mise en oeuvre de ce
test sur ces automates là ces automates
permettent en moins d'une heure de poser
un diagnostic d'infection par la
covid-19
fin de la formation les élèves échangent
avec le médecin en chef Charles affecté
à la Marine nationale en fonction de ta
mission si ta mission va t'amener être
en situation très isolée éloigné des
côtes notamment je pense aux
transatlantique ou entre l'un des
Djibouti à ces moments où tu te
retrouves dans ce qu'on appelle en blue
water ou tu sais qu'il y a plus de 48
heures de navigation même pour une
portée hélicoptère pour pouvoir
rejoindre une côte là tu as intérêt à le
demander parce que ça peut clairement
changer la donne en pleine mer le
médecin embarqué travaille parfois en
totale autonomie toutes les technologies
capables de réduire son isolement sont
les bienvenus
Charles est l'un des premiers à avoir
testé en conditions réelles ce
laboratoire embarqué
il a participé avec un autre médecin à
l'expérimentation réalisée en 2018 sur
deux frigades de défense aérienne
notre expérience de ces appareils qui a
amené à valider finalement entre
guillemets le besoin et et là et affiné
quels automates étaient les plus
performants et les plus intéressants sur
le plan clinique et à partir de là il y
a eu donc le développement sur d'autres
bâtiments l'informatisation est
maintenant ces mini automates on a gagné
on a gagné en efficacité en justesse de
résultats et en praticité
l'innovation en médecine de guerre c'est
aussi mieux comprendre l'état de santé
du combattant du Grand Nord au désert du
Sahel le militaire évolue parfois dans
des conditions climatiques hostiles
difficile d'être performant en toute
circonstance
au Mali par exemple les températures
dépassent facilement les 50 degrés en
Guyane le taux d'humidité grimpe souvent
à plus de 80%. résultat le service de
santé des armées doit développer son
savoir-faire dans tous les
environnements
[Musique]
en fonction vous allez porter et vous
allez ajuster vraiment sous sous les
pectoraux et qui va enregistrer votre
écrans de chaleur lors d'un récent
entraînement ce malaise allait fort
touche une centaine de militaires par an
sans qu'on puisse réellement détecter la
cause pour avoir des choses
[Musique]
on a du mal à identifier une population
à risque donc c'est tout le sujet de
l'étude qu'on fait à l'heure actuelle
c'est d'essayer de voir s'il y a des
facteurs qui peuvent nous des facteurs
de risque si vous voulez qu'on peut
identifier de manière un peu plus claire
de gens qui sont riches donc un coup de
chaleur allez tout va bien pas du
deuxième tour jusqu'en 2014-2015 sur le
plan médicaux militaire les gens étaient
inapte un coup de cœur d'exercices
c'était inapte à toute activité physique
dans les armées donc avec des grosses
conséquences en termes de carrière
ça ça a changé et on essaie de faire
évoluer si vous voulez la réglementation
au fur et à mesure qu'on fait qu'on
progresse dans notre étude
52 13 évidemment quand on est militaire
impossible de faire l'impasse sur
l'activité physique
un quart d'heure après parce qu'on a
besoin d'avoir la chute de température
si on ne fait pas un entraînement
rigoureux et intense on ne peut pas
envoyer
nos soldats sur les Théas d'opération ça
elle de manière efficace le but
justement c'est de pousser
l'entraînement pour que pour pouvoir
traiter détecter les sujets à risque
durant l'entraînement plutôt et éviter
que ce genre de situation apparaisse en
situation opérationnelle généralement ce
qu'on fait c'est que on maintient une
activité physique
à son rythme mais très régulière c'est
ce qui permet aussi de tolérer la
chaleur et puis l'entraînement aussi
avant de partir il faut une excellente
condition physique que ce soit pour
supporter les exercices physiques à pied
mais même supporter des chaleurs dans
les véhicules qui peuvent dépasser les
52 degrés
pour aller plus loin dans la recherche
l'institut de recherche biomédicale des
armées l'IRBA s'est doté d'une toute
nouvelle chambre bioclimatique sur son
site de Brétigny-sur-Orge en banlieue
parisienne
en plus des études de terrain cette
plateforme doit permettre de tester sur
les militaires toutes sortes de scénaris
climatiques dans des conditions
parfaitement contrôlées
principales c'est généré donc dans un
volume déterminé des conditions de
température qui vont de moins 20 plus 70
de générer un hygrométrie qui va de 10 à
98% et d'avoir un vent jusqu'à 22 mètres
seconde
en plus on a une certaine homogénéité
qui est liée à cet environnement et qui
nous permet de recréer en permanence et
de reproduire en permanence les
conditions environnementales que l'on
reproductive on voudrait progresser pour
comprendre quels sont en amont de ça les
sujets particulièrement à risque
quels sont ceux qui vont récidiver ou
pas parce que ça a un impact
effectivement sur la projection
opérationnelle des sujets et une fine et
on voudrait effectivement proposer des
contre-mesures qui soient adaptées aux
différents sujets il n'est pas question
d'aller rendre inapte un sujet par
rapport à une signature biologique telle
ou telle bien évidemment éthiquement
c'est un concevable par contre lui
proposer effectivement une adaptation
peut-être un peu plus longue pour
celui-là peut-être en amont de la
projection ça c'est des choses
effectivement qui peuvent avoir du sens
en terme effectivement entre guillemets
de médecine personnalisée ou voilà
d'acclimatation personnalisée de mesure
de protection personnalisée en fonction
de votre carte biologique
à quelques pas de là à l'irbat toujours
d'autres chercheurs travaillent sur un
autre genre de problématique les
maladies infectieuses
l'objectif développer des moyens et
contre-mesures médicales pour protéger
le combattant des mars ce dernier le
site a adapter son activité pour
répondre à l'épidémie de covid-19 en
France
armées ont été soumises comme le
l'ensemble de la nation à des cette
infections avec la survenue de cluster
on a donc fallu s'adapter développer un
certain nombre de techniques le site
dispose d'une chaîne complète de
diagnostic et de séquençage pour
identifier rapidement les virus
une configuration rare en France qui
existe grâce à des équipements de pointe
notamment des laboratoires de sécurité
biologique de niveau 2 3 et
prochainement de niveau 4 habilité à
étudier des agents pathogènes plus ou
moins dangereux pour mieux s'en protéger
la covid 19 de niveau 3 y est étudié
sous tous ses aspects le but mieux
connaître le virus les mécanismes de
l'infection et les moyens de défense
nous avons une chaîne de diagnostic qui
est basée sur les tests de PCF c'est un
test qui permet d'identifier le les
gènes qui sont présents dans le virus
cette chaîne de diagnostic a été mise en
place dès le début de la crise covid et
a permis de participer donc à les Front
national de diagnostic au profit des
forces armées et de la population
ensuite ce virus est mieux caractérisé
tout d'abord nous allons essayer de
trouver la séquence du virus nous avons
donc développé des techniques très
particulières qui permettent de
d'identifier ce virus et de voir comment
il évolue au cours du temps et même de
retrouver au sein des populations
comment ils passent de personnes à
personne et pourra suivre sa route
enfin nous pouvons étudier la réponse
immunitaire dirigée contre ce virus par
les techniques de sérologie donc on
regarde la production d'anticorps
dirigés contre les virus et de sérum
neutralisation là nous regardons si les
anticorps sont efficaces ils peuvent
bloquer l'entrée du virus
ok super est aussi doté d'un microscope
électronique unique en Europe capable
d'examiner de manière très fine la
structure des virus et des bactéries
dans le futur nous pourrons adapter la
chaîne que nous avons mis en place pour
la covid-19 sur les futurs virus
émergents et nous sommes d'ores et déjà
prêts pour tout virus de classe 3 ou
classe 4 qui pourrait survenir et poser
un problème pour les forces armées ou
pour la nation la crise sanitaire a vu
se multiplier les initiatives médicales
innovantes
retour à Toulon à l'hôpital
l'instruction des armées Sainte-Anne le
service anesthésie expérimente un
système intelligent de surveillance à
distance des patients pour optimiser
leurs prises en charge et soulager le
personnel soignant
un dispositif qui résulte de l'appel à
projet lancé par l'agence de
l'innovation de défense
[Musique]
un peu la blouse on a un biopatch qui
est une durée de vie de 5 jours qui nous
permet de recueillir des données en
continu en plus de la surveillance
infirmière lors de leur tour toutes les
quatre à six heures
fréquence cardiaque fréquence
respiratoire température c'est constant
de vitales sont compilés dans une
application connectée au système et qui
alerte en fonction de la gravité de
l'état du patient
et donc à distance ça me permet de
d'avoir un premier coup d'oeil à une
première évaluation de mes patients
hospitalisés dans les étages ça me
permet de prioriser les patients à les
voir
le plus rapidement
le système qui relie pour l'instant deux
patients devraient à terme équiper les
40 lits du service
dans les secteurs accueillant les
malades de la covid 19
la fréquence respiratoire c'est vraiment
paramètres physiologique dont on a
l'intuition
qu'elle permet précocement de détecter
les risques de dégradation chez les
patients tous les systèmes qui vont nous
permettre de repérer ces patients avant
qu'il soit au stade de la dégradation et
qui vont nous permettre de faire une
intervention thérapeutique qui va
peut-être le rééviter d'aller en
réanimation et d'avoir ce chemin de
soins un peu compliqué sont intéressants
et on pense que le système que là on est
en train d'essayer peut nous aider à
limiter ce type de d'évolution
si les concluants ce système pourrait
être étendu à l'ensemble des hôpitaux
militaires
mais le médecin voit plus loin jusque
sur les théâtres d'opérations
notre arrière-pensée c'est un jour de
pouvoir déployer ce type de système
quand la technologie aura évolué à
l'avant avec des patients qui seront
pris en charge avant leur arrivée à
l'hôpital qui seront monitorés par ce
type de dispositif et qui seront
surveillés peut-être par les équipes
hospitalières dans l'attente de leur
admission tout ça est potentiellement
très intéressant également pour
l'opération extérieure et la prise en
charge du décès de guerre on l'a vu pour
la crise covid 19 on l'a vu également
pour la crise pour la Ebola donc le
service Santé des Armées a pu
effectivement transposer son
savoir-faire
au monde civil et montrer donc ses
capacités d'adaptation et de réactivité
l'élément militaire de réanimation le
maire et puis s'adapter à une crise
sanitaire et montrer à quel point le
service Santé des Armées était capable
de réagir très vite et de se mettre en
situation et de s'adapter à une nouvelle
crise
autre exemple le dispositif d'évacuation
médicale aéroportée Morphée ou le module
de réanimation pour les opérations mes
robes
à l'origine pensez pour des soldats
blessés sur des théâtres d'opérations
lointains ils ont été déployés sur le
territoire français pour évacuer des
malades de la covid-19
[Musique]
la ministre des armées a présenté la
nouvelle feuille de route du service de
santé des armées en tirant les
enseignements de la crise de la covid-19
le budget du service sera augmenté de
160 millions d'euros d'ici à 2025 et
l'accent se rapporte notamment sur le
ravitaillement sanitaire et la recherche
sur le risque biologique